I wanna make a bet with you today yes a
bet I'm willing to bet you by the time
you're done watching this video one of
two things gonna happen to you either
you can have tears coming down your eyes
you're gonna cry we're gonna have the
chills all of your buttocks that's what
happens I mean if it does if you do cry
and if you do get the chills all of your
body I want you to text five people this
story this link and if you don't tweet
me any question I'll respond back to you
fair enough
this is a story about a horse and if you
don't know I love horses I love
everything about horses I love horse
movie Secretariat Seabiscuit champ with
Jon Voight back in the days I probably
watched Jon Voight 50 times in Iran
until I finally met John was just a very
emotional movie to me
I love horse paintings I love growing a
racetrack I love going to the Derby I
love going to Kentucky Derby
I love horses but this is a story about
an owner and a horse he didn't believe
in it's a story of an owner names as I
yet and this is a man very wealthy man
he's been in a horse business for a very
very long time and every year horse
owners go to this auction and they bet
on horses and they buy horses now is
that yet who I believe was an Egyptian
millionaire he not only by sources he
also sells his own horses
so in this auction he sold one of his
horses he just didn't believe this horse
was gonna do good so he gave it up to
auction so everybody these millionaires
they bring different analysts these are
people that calculated which horse is
gonna do good based on certain data that
they pull up right and so this guy
brings a guy named Jeff now Jeff for you
to know he's very decked out very
educated brilliant guy he's a guy that
was in Wall Street did very well in his
mid late 20s and then he got bored he
says like I love horses I'm just gonna
get into the horse business and he came
out with a formula on how to pick
winning horses and it's very different
than some of the other people are they
picked their horses sure it's okay go at
it let me know which horse I should bet
on subscribe so Jeff goes and starts
doing this investigation and by the way
these horses don't have names they're
typically year old and they have numbers
like it's not gonna be certain name
you're gonna do number 86 number 129
that's what your bind your binding
number right so Jeff goes and does his
due diligence and it comes back and say
it says okay so who should I buy he says
uh there's not a single horse for you to
buy today he says what do you mean and
that one horse there's not a single
horse that's worth you investing money
it says how about that one horse what a
great pet
waste of time don't do it so what do I
do he says look I think the best horse
for you to bet on this year for the
Derby Derby is the horse you put up for
auction he says wait a minute the horse
that I'm selling that I sold yes do you
want me to buy back my own horse that's
like comical yes you got to go back and
buy that horse it's kind of weird
why do you say that let me explain to
you why so they pull up the data and
here's the data is that horse just so
you know when it came to height he was
in the 56 percentile of height you know
what that means you know how parents go
to the doctor and doctor says your
four-year-old son is in the 89th
percentile what does that mean out of
100 kids he's gonna be taller than 89 of
them this horse was in the 56 percentile
when it came down to the weight he was
in the 61 percentile light horse short
horse when he came down to pedigree
ready
70% ah nothing impressive but Jeff
Telles I yet when it comes down to his
hearts left ventricle ready ninety nine
point six one percentile let me say this
again ninety nine point six one
percentile that means out of a thousand
horses only three of them have a bigger
left ventricle you got a bet on this
horse cuz he's got a big heart and he's
gonna fight and when you race you need a
horse with a big heart
the owner says oh my gosh I hope you're
right and make sense cuz a lot of open
lot all these you know predictive
analytics they like to look at guys
would be horses with big nostrils I says
no no no it's all about the left
ventricle so it gets this horse you know
what he ends up naming this horse doing
that he bought back the one that he
didn't believe in ready American Pharoah
you know what American throws in 2015
American flora does in 2015 something
that no horse had done for 39 years
American Pharoah goes and wins the
Triple Crown second fastest time ever
not only that American Pharoah wins the
Breeders Cup
that same year never been done before
not only does he win the Breeders Cup he
wins by six and a half lengths now what
does this have to do with anything
this was a special horse butt pad I mean
that's great that he won all that stuff
what's your point in 2006 two
billionaires fought for one horse
because that horse had such great height
weight pedigree everybody wanted to
source great pedigree you know what they
paid for that horse 16 million dollars
you can go to your own research 2006
most expensive horse ever bought an
option you'll see 16 million dollars do
you know what that horses courier
earnings was ever-ready
ten thousand dollars sixteen million
dollars ten thousand dollars what does
this have to do with you everything see
back in 2009 I was in a meeting and I'll
never forget this the chairman the
company got up and he said every ten
years I pick somebody that I believe is
gonna be the future of the industry and
I Bank on him for a decade
and everyone sitting in the room it
wasn't a lot of people that were waiting
to see what name was gonna be mentioned
the names were brought up wasn't my name
i sat in that room and I said wow you
picked the guy that played professional
sports for college you picked the guy
that is American I'm Middle Eastern I
don't have a degree I never played
organized sports
you picked the guy that looked the part
you picked the guy that everything made
sense good pedigree everything was
proper but he never saw the heart you
never saw the character I said no
problem do you know how many times I
replayed that talk in my own mind so
many times you know why see why you're
watching this some of you may be seen I
wish I was taller I wish had better skin
I wish I were a nicer eyes I wish my
nose was smaller I wish I was a little
bit stronger I wish I was a better
communicator I wish had a better degree
I wish my parents were Kennedy sort of
Rockefellers or the Vanderbilts I don't
know I just wish my parents had a name I
mean I wish I had those contacts I wish
my parents did something with their
lives see those things don't matter what
matters is what nobody sees and it's
right here it's your left ventricle it's
your heart
people can't see this everybody sees
degrees everybody sees height everybody
sees last name nobody sees the heart I'm
in my garage right now it's 12:30 Sunday
night kids are sleeping upstairs you can
see the light just went off you know why
cuz I don't want to make a lot of noise
these kids are asleep I got to go to
school early in the morning you know
what I think about all the time as I'm
chasing and I'm going after my vision of
what I want to do I think about that
heart no one knows your heart so as
you're watching this and you're a little
bit down on yourself maybe not
everything's going right do not let the
world judge you on the outside go show
the world what's on the inside and by
the way if you get the chills and if you
got tears in your eyes right now
pay your bet text us to five other
people because I bet there's other
people that also need to hear this
message and if I lost send me a tweet
I'll answer any question may have but
either way have a killer week this week
love you